all right my talk on the table is the
crazy good acclaimed show Yellow Jackets
returning for its highly anticipated
second season part psychological
Thriller part Survival Story the show
takes place in two timelines 25 years
apart in one a group of mostly teenage
girls fights to stay alive after their
plane crashes in a remote forest in 1996
and in the other timeline several of the
now adult survivors are haunted by their
past and are still trying to escape what
happened in that Wilderness Christina
Ricci was nominated for an Emmy for
playing the adult Misty a mysterious and
manipulative Survivor in the clip you're
about to see Misty searches for her
missing friend take a look
what happened to the woman in room 135
let me check my records
you're not doing anything
huh
let me try again
brunette stunning looks like she'd stab
you
she's my best friend and she wouldn't
have left town without telling me so
something must have happened to her
something happens to all of us
true
and some of those things can be worse
than others depending on our choices
Larry frankowski's 65 Union Street
Apartment 2v
remind me Larry is your social security
number
138-00-2671 or is it now
I'm pretty sure that's it
oh Larry go go Yellow Jackets is a
production of Showtime which like CBS is
part of Paramount Global but it is a
darn good show Christina Ricci joins us
now Christina thank you very much for
being here oh thank you so much for
having me season one ends with a
cliffhanger season two you get the
scripts what'd you think what were your
reactions and what can people expect
well season one was had moments that
were very like outrageous and shocking
for sure daring and I have to say the
scripts for season two every time they
came in I mean I would audibly gasp
reading them like it just gets in a good
way yes like oh my God I can't believe
this is happening kind of way
um it's even more sort of like shocking
and crazy and really fun
no you've described your character Misty
as a murderous golden retriever
[Laughter]
what is it about this character that
makes it appealing well I really I loved
her as soon as I read you know and I
only read the one scene she had from the
pilot before I signed on and in it she
is she abuses an elderly person under
her care and I just was sort of I've
always been sort of very interested by
deviant behavior and like the kind of
person that feels so small and Petty
that they have to you know they take
power in these ways and Misty is such a
fun character because she's always been
rejected you know she has no social
currency she's not cool she's not hot
she's not funny and she's missing sort
of this moral compass that everybody
else has but somehow it allows her to
even through like her isolation and
being rejected she just has the most fun
she loves chaos she never has the same
like pathos as anybody else you know she
doesn't really understand why everyone
feels so ashamed of everything all the
time and she just like has a really good
time and is wonderfully passive
aggressive and it's just fun sounds like
it well you know this is an All-Star
cast of women what what does that mean
to you you know it's really really
wonderful and we had so many days of
shooting where I would look around our
green room and it was like five women in
their 40s like playing really
complicated flawed characters and it was
just great to be a part of something
that where you know middle-aged women
are carrying a lot of it so it's hard to
see you as middle age well I am
hard for me too I feel your pain but
still in your Prime that's right which
means we are as well because I remember
Watching You on The Addams Family in the
90s we played Wednesday shot to stardom
as a result and and over the career that
followed you played some darker roles uh
I got a message a few just a few I I'm
curious what attracts you to those roles
and also when people come up to you on
the street having played those roles
what are their reactions like
I do I mean when I was younger I had a
lot more people like coming up and
saying aren't you a witch and all this
stuff and I was like no I just played
some unhappy people
um I uh I don't know I've just always
been really I love human behavior I I
love the complexities also it's fun as
an actress to do something different to
do something not every not that
something you've never seen before you
know
um to react in unconventional ways as a
character and uh I don't know I've just
always been attracted to stuff that
seems a little bit off track you've been
in this business for a long time it's
quickly for young people that are at
home and they're thinking about taking
the same Journey what would be your
advice to them I would say I and I think
this is good advice for any kind of
artist
um you know find the thing that really
you only you can do the thing that makes
you special even if it's not popular
right now and cultivate that thing that
only you can bring you know I think
there's so much pressure especially when
you're young to sort of conform and do
what's popular right when you find that
the people that ultimately really
succeed and leave a mark are people
who've done something completely
different and good advice yeah
absolutely and who have mad shoe game
we're shooting I know we I saw that I
love it
thank you very much thank you for being
here season two of Yellowjackets
premieres March 24th on Showtime and you
can see more of Christina Ricci tonight
on The Late Show with Stephen Colbert
right here on CBS yellowjack it's such a
good show